So to make this work out, we'll just make a little contract with ourselves.
Let's assume that when we're interpreting JavaScript and we come across a call to write
we'll just figure out what the argument is--that will be some string--
and we'll append it to a special "javascript--space--output" variable
that we'll store in the global environment.
Global because you could call write from anywhere.
Everyone has to be able to see it.
So here is our glorious JavaScript interpreter, or at least the parts of it that you
haven't already written.
We're given the abstract syntax tree, which contains a list of JavaScript elements.
The first thing we do is make a global environment.
Global environments have no parent pointers.
This would be a parent pointer, but instead it's none.
We're going to start it out with the variable "javascript--space--output",
mapping to the empty string.
Then for every element in the embedded JavaScript code,
we evaluate that element--you've already seen how to do that--in the global environment.
This might make changes to it over time through calls to environment update.
At the end of the day, the string we return is, well, we have the global environment
right here.
We get its 1th element, which is this mapping, and we get out the current value
of "javascript output," which hopefully has changed.
So it's quiz time.
You've seen our assumption, and we've written out the code for the JavaScript interpreter,
at least at the top level.
Here I've written 3 sentences.
We could rename "javascript--space--output" to anything as long as we're consistent.
"Javascript--space--output" is a good choice because it has a space in it,
and "javascript--space--output" starts empty, mapping to the empty string
to support 0 calls to write.
Multiple, multiple choice--check each one of these that's true.